When it comes to exporting and importing your animation assets and your characters,
it's important to be aware of some of the settings that you need to get accurate results.
So I'm going to go over some of the settings for a few different softwares.
We'll look at Maya, we'll look at 3ds Max and Blender,
as these are some of the most popular external animation softwares that people tend to use.
If you're exporting from Maya, make sure that you select all of the joints in your skeleton,
as well as the skinned mesh,
and choose File, Export.
Change the export type to FBX,
and make sure that you tick the animation checkbox,
so that the animation comes out with the export.
Make sure at the bottom of the window here you have deformed models, skins and blend shapes ticked
if they're relevant for your character.
One thing to note is if you want the smoothing information for your character,
disable Smooth Mesh, and instead tick the Smoothing Groups option.
Now this allows Unreal to calculate the smoothing of the mesh more accurately,
and gives you more control over the smoothing on import.
Exporting from 3ds Max is very, very similar to Maya,
so just make sure that you have all of your assets selected that you want to export.
In the export options, keep animation ticked,
and make sure deformations, skins and morph targets are also all ticked.
If you're using Blender to animate with,
Epic have actually created a plugin that allows you to send your animation straight from Blender to the engine,
and this can also include your rig from Blender as well.
Now Epic has a YouTube playlist that goes over how to install this and how to use the plugin,
which should speed up your workflow when you're sending stuff from Blender over to the engine.
If you're not using that Unreal plugin,
what you can do is just use the default exporter within Blender.
So in the FBX export settings,
set the forward axis to X forward to match Unreal's forward axis,
and make sure that you disable add leaf bones.
Uncheck bake animation, and then smoothing groups aren't a concept in Blender,
so apply any smoothing modifiers before you export.
So your auto smooth, your edge split, anything like that you need to apply,
get that done before you're doing your export.
Something to keep in mind for anything you're exporting from Blender is the default units.
So in Blender, the default is one meter per unit.
However, in Unreal, it's one centimeter per unit.
So whether you convert that on import,
or whether you make a change to your Blender settings,
it's just worth keeping that in mind and knowing that there's a difference there.
Now that we know how to correctly export animations from these external softwares,
let's take a look and see how we can do that in engine,
as well as importing into the engine, both your first character, as well as new animations.
So exporting from engine is quite straightforward, actually.
You just find the animation that you want to export in your content browser,
right click, go to asset actions, and then export.
It'll ask you where you want to save it, so we'll just put it on the desktop for now,
and we'll keep the name as it is,
and then you'll get the FBX export options window come up,
which I'll just make a little bit bigger.
Now, a lot of these options you probably don't need to have ticked
when you're just exporting an animation.
So if you untick vertex color and level of detail, as well as collision,
something you may or may not want to tick is export preview mesh.
If you just want the animation information and the joints,
then you can uncheck this.
But if you want to see the character's mesh as well,
then you should keep that checked.
And then all you need to do is press export.
One thing to note that any meshes that you do export from the engine
will come out triangulated.
And that's just because when you import the mesh into the engine,
Unreal automatically triangulates it just for hardware optimization.
Before you can bring any animations into the engine,
the first thing that you need to do is bring in your character.
And that character is going to include the skeleton
that the animations will play on and the skeletal mesh,
which is essentially the mesh of the character.
So let's go ahead and do that now.
So inside your content browser, if you just click import,
find your character, hit open,
and because we know we want to bring a skeletal mesh in,
there's a skeletal mesh filter option just here.
And this will eliminate all the options that are unnecessary
for this type of import, this type of asset that we're bringing in.
So leaving everything as it is at default,
if I just press import,
you'll see that our characters come in here, our skeleton,
as well as the skeletal mesh.
Now that we have our character in the engine,
we can actually start to bring an animation in.
So this is a similar process.
Find wherever it is you want to store your animation,
and just press import.
We'll use the one that we exported earlier,
and we'll just press open.
Now, because this is an animation, again, we can use the filters here,
so we'll just check animations there.
And automatically, it's chosen my character skeleton
as the skeleton that we want to use.
If it doesn't do that, then you should choose this dropdown
and select your skeleton from the list
because we don't want to bring in any of the skeleton
or the mesh information from this file.
We just want to bring in the animation information.
So if we tick import animations,
and just scroll down a little
because that threw us a little higher up.
There we go.
Oh, no, sorry.
There we go, import animations.
Make sure import bone tracks is ticked.
And under the animation length here,
you've got three different options.
So more often than not,
you'll export from frame 0 to frame whatever, call it 100,
essentially from the first to the last frame of your animation.
And when that's the case,
you just keep this as default set to source timeline,
and that will automatically bring in the entire animation.
And you can select also animated time,
and this imports the range of frames that have animation on them.
And alternatively, you could set a range
and then choose the minimum frame and the maximum frame
of that range that you want to bring in.
By default, the sample rate or the frame rate is 30 FPS.
If yours is different from that,
you can use a custom sample rate,
and you just enter that here,
and then you just press import.
And here we can see our animation
laying on our character.
So it really is quite straightforward.
So now that we've imported our characters
and we've imported our animations into the engine,
what if you make a change to that character or to that animation
and you want to reimport it and bring it back in?
Well, it's actually quite straightforward.
So with animations,
if you right-click them and choose reimport,
as long as you've overwritten that file inside File Explorer,
it will just bring the same file back in
and any edits that you've made and you've overwritten with,
it will reimport that information.
If you wanted to bring in a new file,
or you saved the file somewhere else,
you could reimport with new file.
And this will bring you to your File Explorer,
and you can find the file that you want,
press open, and that'll bring that back in.
The options also exist inside the animation asset itself.
So if we were to open that up,
on the top bar here,
you can see that you can reimport the animation,
and that will do the same thing
It'll find the existing file inside your File Explorer,
and as long as you've overwritten it with your new export,
it'll just bring that straight back in.
And if you want to change any of the reimport options,
you can choose reimport animation with dialogue,
and that brings up your import options.
And anything that you wanted to change in here, you could do.
If you wanted to assign it to a different skeleton,
change the frame rate, anything like that,
you could then change those options and press import.
If you want to reimport the character itself,
you could do that in a similar way to the animation.
All you have to do is right-click the character,
reimport or reimport with new file,
and that'll give you the same options,
or that will reimport in the same way that the animation did.
Or you could open the asset,
and again, you have a reimport mesh option at the top here,
but you also have these three dots,
so you have some extra options.
So you could do the same two options here,
reimport mesh or reimport with new file,
or you could bring in the mesh and the levels of detail,
so the LODs.
Same thing with the new file.
And if there's just specific things like the geometry
or the skin weights that you want to bring in,
you could do that too.
And the same options exist over here
with the addition of the import dialogue option box.
So if you were to select one of those,
you'd get this option box to come up again,
and you could change any of these settings that were relevant.
Another way to add animations to your project
would be to purchase them from the Unreal Fabstore.
So once you've purchased an animation pack from the Fabstore,
you would then find it in your Unreal Engine library,
and it's as simple as clicking Add to Project
and choosing the project that you want to add it to.
Now, what you'll probably find
is that any animations that you download
will very likely be for a different skeleton,
meaning they'll come in with its own skeleton
and its own skeletal mesh.
And what you'll need to do there
is use Unreal Engine's retargeting tool,
which is very simple, very robust.
If you right-click, choose Retarget,
and retarget those animations to your own skeleton,
you'll find that those animations should work.
Now, most animations on the store
will note whether or not they're compatible
with the Unreal Engine skeleton.
And if that is something you are using,
then a lot of the times,
it will automatically work on that skeleton
without you having to do anything.
But if not, you can use Unreal Engine
retargeting tools, because they're very, very simple,
and as I say, very robust.